el presidente de ucrania ha vuelto a
personalizar los mensajes que están
llevando a cabo en los parlamentos
mundiales esta vez en su conferencia en
el congreso de los diputados de españa
de lenski comparó el asedio y los
crímenes contra civiles que el ejército
ruso está cometiendo en su país con el
bombardeo de la ciudad del país vasco-
de gernika durante la guerra civil
española y por eso dijo que aunque
estemos en abril de 2022 parece que
estemos en abril de 1937 hay en el que
sucedió este ataque al igual que hizo
durante el consejo de seguridad de la
onu pidió que los actores de esos
crímenes sean llevados frente a la corte
penal internacional
helens que agradeció la ayuda recibida
desde españa pero pidió más armamento y
que se sigan apoyando futuras sanciones
y que éstas sean más contundentes ya que
la agresión rusa dijo el presidente
ucraniano empezó hace ya muchos años no
sólo hace 41 días que el objetivo de
putin es destruir la posibilidad de
vivir en democracia por su parte el
presidente del gobierno de españa
condenó una vez más la guerra despiadada
de putin a quien llamó a sentarse en la
mesa de negociación para acabar con el
conflicto prometió más armas y más ayuda
humanitaria
y anunció el apoyo de españa a una
posible adhesión de ucrania a la unión
europea afirmó que ucrania es un ejemplo
de dignidad y de resistencia y que el
país es ahora mismo la esperanza de
europa además hoy mismo españa anunció
la expulsión de 25 diplomáticos y
personal de la embajada rusa porque
según el ministro de asuntos exteriores
suponen una amenaza a la seguridad de
españa sin embargo mantendrán al
embajador ruso en españa porque quieren
dejar abierta alguna vía diplomática